اليوم الخامس عشر من الحرب أين يقف من أجل فهمك
أعتقد أننا وصلنا إلى مرحلة حرجة للغاية
في القتال داخل غزة ويجب أن نفهم ذلك جيداً
وصلنا إلى مرسي إلى مخيم رفح المليونين
اللاجئون الذين فر بعضهم
من الشمال، بكثافة رهيبة، من السهل الدخول هناك
كل هيل وشيء دمره لديه آلاف الأعمدة الأخرى
هناك 100 قناة أخرى والقنوات القليلة التي ظهرت
وهذا يعني مئات الكيلومترات من القنوات الإضافية
وحتى لا يكون هناك حل لهذا الخراج فلا يوجد نصر
حماس دون الاستيلاء على الحدود دون الاستيلاء عليها
لا يمكن كسب هذه الحرب على محور فيلادلفيا
لا يمكنك الفوز في الحرب، عليك أن تواجه الحقيقة
أن نقول ذلك، لا أن نروي القصص، نحن نحن
ونحن سوف اقول لك كيف
في رأيي، أصبح الأمر أكثر صعوبة اليوم بالنسبة لك ولماتيد
ومن الأسهل على حماس إعادة المختطفين اليوم
يذهب
إلى اتفاق مع
أما حماس حيث تذهب إلى خطة لإطلاق سراح المختطفين
لقد قلنا طوال الوقت ونقول مرة أخرى
ومرة أخرى قدمت لنا الأهداف القتالية صراعا
أسرة حماس وعودة المختطفين لا يجتمعان
القتال يعرضهم للخطر وإذا كان هناك طريقة لإخراجهم
الطريقة الوحيدة هي الصفقة وإذا كان لها ثمن
ضع السعر لأنني أقول مرة أخرى
بقدر ما يهمني، الآن يتم الكذب علينا والتضحية بنا
التخلي عنهم الآن وعندما أقول ذلك
أقصد بعض الأشخاص في الحكومة الحالية
وما زالوا يقولون القتال فقط مدينة الملجأ القتالية
في العالم سنكون بنيامين، وسوف تبدأ في الارتعاش
من الآن فصاعدا لن تساعدك الحبوب، نحن واقفون
لقد كنت هنا لمدة 105 يومًا
ونتوسل إليهم أن يعيدوا أحبائنا إلى وطنهم
وتحول التوسل من أجل عودتهم إلى مناشدة
لإنقاذ حياتهم نطالب بعقد مؤتمر
الدولي الآن قطر مصر الولايات المتحدة
وإسرائيل التي جلست في ممر واحد ورتبت
سوف تتوصل الأمور إلى فهم لكيفية قضاء
المختطفون يعودون إلى بيوتهم، نطالبك يا سيد نتنياهو
سوف يجتمع معنا في الليلة التي حرر فيها الأطفال و أنت
عائلاتنا يوم الأحد تقضي ليالٍ في الخارج
الجدول لا ترفضهم لا تلغيهم أنت
يرى طريقة ما للتوصل إلى اتفاق لإطلاق سراح 136
مختطفون أو على الأقل معظمهم في الواقع الذي نعيشه
نحن نتحدث عن صفقة سابقة تمكنا من التوصل إليها
إيليا أعتقد أنه ليس لدينا خيار سوى
السنوار هو من سيقرر موعد إطلاق سراحهم
الفازينر هو الذي سيحدد أيضًا ما هي الشروط
من أجل إطلاق سراحهم
وفي رأيي إذا أنهينا هذه الحرب
136 رون ريد و136 حكومة لدولة إسرائيل
خسرت الحرب لأول مرة منذ بدايتها
والثمن الذي يطلبه السنوار في هذه اللحظة هو القطيعة
والحرب هي أن البنادق هي البنادق لحماس كل يوم
بعد الإصدار سندخل مرة أخرى ونقوم بتصفيته ثم السعر
ما تقوله هو في الواقع ترك حكم حماس
اشتري وفقًا للمنطق الذي تقدمه أو يتم تقديمه
أولئك الذين يحتفظون به، لن يطلق سراحه أبدا
لهم وأنه عندما يموت ربما لن يكون هناك أحد للتحدث معه
للإفراج
هم
وفي رأيي أن ما يجب على إسرائيل أن تقلق بشأنه هو الدولة
وعلى إسرائيل أن تصحح الفعل الذي أدى إلى التخلي عنها
وخيانة الدولة لمواطنيها ومن قبلها
أعدها فلن تكون قادرة على التفكير في أي شيء
خطوط النصر كان بعيدًا جدًا عن الضغط بالمناسبة
وما زال اليوم
نحن بعيدون جداً عن حسم المناورة بالنسبة للبلد
هناك ترتيب للأولويات إذا قررت دولة إسرائيل ذلك
حكومة إسرائيل اتخذت قراراً اتخذه رئيس وزراء إسرائيل
للتخلي عن
المختطفين ويتسبب في موت آخر شيطان فيهم
دعه يقول ذلك بصوت عالٍ للجمهور وما نحن عليه
ترى الآن أن هذا نوع من الهزائم التي لا أساس لها
الهزائم إن شئت تلطخ قطاع غزة بطريقتي الخاصة
ولا بد من الإشارة قليلاً أيضاً إلى المؤسسة الأميركية
في العراق